uh uh okay so plugs i met
two is that gonna be with harry fraud
oh harry frog oh harry frog paul harry
fraud
yup yup now give me the timeline we know
july 31st we're getting the gangster
girl
the boy talk about this uh [ __ ]
july
30 i was waiting july 31st we got the
respected sopranos with these guys
yeah what i'm saying and they going
crazy they bombing on this [ __ ]
and we got jonesy on there we got lovey
on there we got the rest of the black
sopranos on there it's crazy
uh september september this is the big
one right here september
we got burden of proof you know what i'm
saying produce
whole solely by hitboy
by the way i've heard i was in the
studio and i've been in with hit
and he's played me all y'all [ __ ] and it
is
yo you guys got hit boy in his boombap
bag something crazy
definitely legend has it legend has it
that this album is perfect
you for what i'm saying no fam i heard i
heard a lot of it and there's some
there's some there's some nice little
features on there right
yes sir yes sir so so
you know what i mean that's that's my
next attempt that's what the streets
been waiting for that's gonna be the
next official release from benny you and
hit boy
now wait benny benny did you get did you
get sean on the project
big sean not yet not yet not yet i
called him the other day like a week ago
like yo bro i need you he's like just
send it
but it's about do i want to use my favor
for this project
of course i do or you know what i mean i
hear you
so you and hit boy so okay so that's
happening in september it's called
burden of proof
burden of proof produced by hitboy man
he gave me he gave me a thousand percent
another person who didn't have to i'm a
lucky [ __ ]
who just didn't have to reach out to me
to work and just it was one of the hills
bro
exactly we put this project together not
knowing it was going to become what it
is today not
knowing we was going to turn down
several million dollar offers for the
project we just enter five you know what
i'm saying it
and we're still dropping the project
independently this is what we do
all right so that's happening in in
september um
what what about the the the double album
and and the album with uh with with
harry fraud are we getting both of those
before
january 1st oh not hell no okay okay i'm
just i'm just trying to i'm just trying
to
see the timeline i'm a visionary i'm a
visionary
and i'm saying i'm always moving 10
steps ahead of ahead of [ __ ] because
that's how i got here so really i got
the uh
burden of proof september you know i'm
saying first quarter
or maybe [ __ ] i might even drop at the
end of this year but that's next on the
calendar is plugs i met two produced by
harry frah i got dope features on there
and then like everybody asks me because
tanner talk three is a work of art
everybody like talk forward coming when
it's gonna talk four coming
i could easily name these projects
tandem talk four and put them out but
yeah and
the tanner talk series is different you
know what i'm saying
and i treat it with care and everybody
been waiting for and i said i gotta live
a little bit more life i gotta
i'm saying things gotta happen in my
life before i feel comfortable calling
another project tana talk
and i feel like i'm at that point now
which project is the drake feature going
to live on
oh man that's a surprise